the Stampede happened in the city of
Malang in East Java Province after a
match between home team arima FC and
their Rivals Surabaya
the chaos began after supporters from
the losing side arima FC invaded the
pitch police responded by firing tear
gas which caused fans to flee for the
exits
many of their friends lost their lives
because of officers who did not humanize
us we're very disappointed with the
treatment because many lives were lost
FIFA's rules ban the use of tear gas by
stewards or police at football matches
East Java's police chief defended the
crowd control measures used by his
officers
it was a feeling of disappointment that
prompted supporters to go down to the
field to ask the players why they lost
the game
that's when the security team moved in
so fans wouldn't get onto the field or
interact with the players during that
process tear gas was fired because there
was Anarchy foreign
police estimate 3 000 fans stormed the
pitch Indonesian president Joko Widodo
has ordered an investigation into the
incident
I have specially requested the police
chief investigates and get to the bottom
of this case furthermore I have also
ordered the Indonesian Football
Association to temporarily halt League
one matches until evaluations and
improvements to the safety procedures
have been completed
[Applause]
42 000 people attended the sellout match
all arima FC supporters Surabaya fans
weren't allowed to buy tickets because
of the risk of violence
I think at this moment FIFA should step
up not by Banning Indonesian football
but working together
guiding our football association with
the right security measures his job as
provincial government says it will give
650 in compensation to the families of
the victims and Promises lessons will be
learned so a tragedy like this doesn't
happen again Victoria gate and beat Al
Jazeera